[Music]
on the last day of black history month
we're highlighting innovators who helped
make our lives easier african americans
have made many contributions to fields
of science and technology their
ingenuity has improved many devices we
use on a daily basis including the
remote control elevator and pencil
shoppers that's just to name a few i
wrote this poem taking a look at some of
the innovative creations made by black
people that make everyday life so much
easier
what have black people done for our
society
well a lot oftentimes without having
propriety to begin my melanin means
excellence with the touch of big mama's
modesty it's up to us to teach our
history properly
because i feel like nobody is as fly as
we
are
with the bird's eye view
paul patton at the helicopter in 62.
george washington carver we're giving
you props
created over 500 products just using his
crops now peanut butter we know god
bless his soul
how about flour vinegar ink dye
cosmetics and soap that's off the top of
the head just to name a few there's
greatness in our bloodline like cr drew
the standard
is to preserve our history like a
refrigerator so we can open up doors
like an elevator
if you don't know then we're miles apart
like edmond be the plug that's providing
a spark yes that's actual facts no
matter how you spin it so love black
people like the things we invented
salute to those before us who made the
sacrifice
in spirit i'm garrett morgan with the
traffic light so keep shifting the game
green means go the world in the palm of
my hands like a remote control hot as a
stove
yeah we extra dough i'm in hotep with a
stethoscope all that means is
i'm ahead of my time listen to the sound
of my soul the thought is simply sublime
open up my heart so you can get that
feeling i'm surgical with the flow dr
daniel h williams i fire burns so strong
there's no putting it out
even tj marshall knows what i'm talking
about self-made like cj walker you can
tell i'm good we have to refine the
track we're on like granville woods
shopping like a pencil from john l love
we want every chip we deserve without
losing a crumb and these are actual
facts no matter how they spin it so love
black people like the things we invented
and for those who are wondering if this
poem is just a flex the question should
be
what are we going to do next
that's a good way that's a good question
although it is a flex that's nicely done
they thank you and i appreciate the
george washington carver reference to
somebody who has peanut butter literally
every single day he's sometimes referred
to as the father of the american peanut
industry exactly i saw you at peanut
butter last week yeah i got it in my
office then come by i knew about the
stoplight i didn't know about the spark
plug yeah so how did you do this nate
did you just pull up different people
and then try to put them in the poem
what was your process black history
month um 2021 i just researched black
inventors and i wanted to write a poem
and then take the money of the proceeds
um and give those back to young black
inventors that want to do something
special after high school so yeah i i
feel like we didn't learn a lot about
black inventors no i was interested no
me neither me neither about more me
neither and i like i like how you ended
the big question is what are we going to
do next we're going to do next that's
right i'm thinking you've got some ideas